[Musique]
maintenant la pierre alias la petite
bête et youtube heuzé blogueuse
professionnel avec l'aide de son
conjoint lionel être est pour nous 8
mandoline on y met une mandoline à quoi
ça sert baquet circonstances on doit
utiliser ça dans mon cas les seules fois
où je veux vraiment voir une mandoline
sais qu'un jour avoir une épaisseur
souhaite vivre vraiment très très fier
comme un carpaccio de battre argent qui
était un mode des tomates quasi
transparente ou gratin du gratin
dauphinois ou le tu veux vraiment que
toutes les pommes de terre soit à
épaisseur égard la majorité coupe très
bien alors l'eau ou une différence au
niveau de la sécurité au niveau de la
stabilité la facilité de nettoyage la
place que ça prend dans ta cuisine parce
qu'on s'en sert pas tout le temps fait
qu'on veut pas voir quelque chose qui
prend la moitié d'une armoire déprimant
pour 1000 cas présumés petits doigts
parce que c'est dangereux la mandoline
mais j'ai une confession à fin jeu
test ligue 1 ok ça va mal
manon a mises à rude épreuve les
mandolines avec toutes sortes de légumes
il nous reste qu on doit manger tous les
miens mon conjoint il s'est coupé le
test ultime ça va être la tomate
si tu arrives à couper quelque chose de
mou et juteux était capable quelque
chose de d'ailleurs aussitôt
donc c'est sûrement déjà arrêté
d'essayer de faire des patates sur les
huit modèles parce que une fois qu'on
était capable de couper ça on savait
qu'on peut couper n'importe quoi
effectivement deux modèles ne passe pas
le test de la tomate ya de la misère
avec la tomate la ricardo sur pattes et
la cuisine pro dans tout ce que ça fait
c'est le morceau de peau parlons d'abord
des quatre modèles sur pattes de
lancement griezmann des liens manon à
rejeter d'emblée la plus chère la
mandoline kitchenaid parce qu'elle est
trop grosse grosse cuisine par contre
elle a et mélanie cardo mais avec
certaines réserves système suis pas un
génie pour le loing sorte sur le dessus
et là on voit que les petites lames sont
là donc c'est ingénieux si je fais un
des juliet gimbel ajustements ça a été
une de mes favorites celle de ricardo
nuit là tu te retrouves les morceaux
d'appeler toyer ça pendant est peut-être
celle ci lâche un peu particulier celle
d un intéressant tout en or de oxo ce
que j'aime c'est que tout rentre
ensemble après tu peux ranger télam
c'est facile à ranger
elle compte bien mais juste une odeur
donc c'est pas juste amenons peu
patente à gosses l'on va se le dire
j'aimais aussi beaucoup celle ci je
trouve que le modèle est ingénieux au
niveau du garde quelqu'un qui a vraiment
le prendre brute des mandolines et qui
doit l'utiliser c'est la plus
sécuritaire son bémol à ce modèle là moi
ça me fatiguait c'est que quand j'allais
8 voilà le constat général dans mon kot
tout les modèles sur pied je les
trouvais un peu grosse pour le besoin et
je trouvais pas nécessairement plus
efficace
les modèles sont peintes un des raisons
que j'ai vraiment pour choisissant comme
modèle c'est que le nettoyage les plus
intenses donc ce qui est arrivé c'est
que cela la compétition a été plus dans
les modèles manuel
parmi les quatre deux modèles ressortent
du lot la ricardo pour leur simple et
bonne raison que lé très faciles à
ajuster au niveau des auteurs à l'une
d'elles l'argent et prend pas de place
en amont par son gros bémol elle ne fait
pas de julien la majorité permettra de
faire de julienne donc soit dit julian
finn certaines faisaient des julienne
plus large aussi et on a juste une qui
faisont julienne sin vraiment car est
attentif et décisif julien qui à la
japonaise cette parfaite c'est la
mandoline bengrine air qui nous offre
cette possibilité
le modèle qui lui offre des causes
multiples et qui est vraiment génial
c'est le modèle japonais
lui coupe les cheveux de dieu comme on
dit le fou l'ajustement est encore le
très simple donc on peut vraiment
ajuster la hauteur la coupe les lever
sur les côtés c'est pour mettre les
autrui la magicienne à l'élan là trois
outils trois types de julienne ça
travaille bien au niveau de la sécurité
de celles là moi le truc qui m'embêtait
ça serait mon numéro un mais j'y mettrai
des bottes en caoutchouc
voilà presque faut faire attention c'est
ça avec sa dette la première fois j'ai
utilisé la japonais je me sens vraiment
à bout de course puis je m'en rappelle
encore
[Musique]